the blaze broke out mid-afternoon at
Marea Detention Center an overcrowded
refugee camp on the Greek island of
Lesbos now look at the people here
fighting look at that look at this fire
big fire yeah big fire people was going
to dead please please for everywhere
country leave the people to war and give
it to the people to go firefighters on
the ground struggled to contain the
blaze and it was eventually extinguished
by an airplane these metal frames are
all that remain of up to seven
containers used to house refugees and
migrants some angry at the time it took
firefighters to respond to the blaze
started rioting police responded with
tear gas aid workers say overcrowding
and heat have made living conditions in
the camp unbearable it was built to look
after 3,000 refugees but now houses
12,000 and is turning away new arrivals
there's been a surge of refugees and
migrants crossing from Turkey to Greece
in recent months despite the 2016 deal
between Turkey and the European Union to
stop it from happening
last month the Greek government agreed
on new measures to deal with the crisis
after nearly 600 people landed on lesbos
the biggest number in three years
refugees are now being transferred to
the mainland and asylum seekers who've
had their applications rejected or to be
deported without appeal but the new
measures are not alleviating quickly
enough the dangerous burden placed on
overcrowded camps Victoria Gaytan B al
Jazeera